he's back on a tennis court after a
victory in a court of law which means
it's advantage djokovic
he wrote despite all that has happened i
want to stay and try to compete at the
australian open i remain focused on that
after four nights in the quarantine
hotel in melbourne the world number
one's case was laid before a judge
it included his pcr certificate for a
positive covid test on december the 16th
in his statement djokovic said the
passport control officer asked me if i
was vaccinated i said no but that i have
a medical exemption
judge anthony kelly backed djokovic and
said he'd done everything he could have
been expected to do the government waved
the white flag they surrendered
and told the court and this is before
the government presented their
counteraction they conceded to the court
that mr jokovic's visa should not be
canceled the decision should be
overturned
on the streets of melbourne the clamor
for him to be freed grew louder
stop this fast and let him play let him
play the australian open it's what he
came out said to do he did all the right
things he followed the rules very
disappointing very embarrassed
serbian supporters then clashed with
police who used pepper spray on the
crowd
tennis is rarely this divisive
in belgrade they have the victory
they've lobbied for perhaps conveniently
the court didn't really get into what
was going on in this photo djokovic with
young serbian tennis players from
december the 17th the day after he
tested positive for covid was on the
17th
okay so uh
this press conference
is a journey at the moment
djokovic now has six days to prepare for
a tournament that could see him crowned
the greatest male tennis player of all
time
but the australian government could yet
scupper him they have the power to
overrule the judge
if they want to
tom parmenter sky
news officials from the united states
and russia held talks in geneva today
aimed at cooling tensions over ukraine
the negotiations come at a time when
relations between the two countries are
at their most fraught since the cold war
this all follows